Elon Musk hat es schon wieder getan.
In Rekordzeit hat er jetzt den Prototypen
des Marsraumschiffes Starship MK1 vorgestellt.
Und die ersten Hoppingtests sind auch schon
vielversprechend gelaufen.
Clixoom Scince & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Was sind das wieder für Bilder!
Bilder, wie ein Blick in die Zukunft, wie
schon die Parallele Landung der beiden Booster
der Falcon Heavy oder der Tesla im Orbit der
Erde.
Musk läßt uns wirklich in die Zukunft schauen,
wie auch jetzt am Wochenende.
Und das ist nur die Spitze der Rakete, das
Transportmodul, in dem bis zu 100 Menschen
zum Mond oder zum Mars reisen können.
Wir hatten ja schon darüber berichtet: „Starship”
ist knapp 55 Meter hoch und soll auf dem Raketenträger
namens “Super Heavy” in den Weltraum fliegen.
Das Raptor-Triebwerk, das “Starship” und
“Super Heavy” antreibt, wurde erst Anfang
des Jahres im Februar 2019 getestet.
Zwei Sekunden lang dauerte das Ganze.
Das Raptor-Triebwerk ist größer als das
Merlin-Triebwerk und liefert so den doppelten
Schub.
Anders als bei Merlin werden auch nicht Kerosin
und flüssiger Sauerstoff, sondern flüssiges
Methan und flüssiger Sauerstoff eingesetzt.
“Starship” soll von sieben Raptor-Triebwerken
ins All befördert werden; die Trägerrakete
“Super Heavy” von 31.
Die Konstruktion von “Starship” ist ganz
besonders: Anders als ursprünglich geplant
wird es nicht Carbonfaser-Mischungen gebaut,
sondern aus Edelstahl-Legierungen.
Musk zufolge soll diese Umstellung einen raschen
und kostengünstigeren Bau möglich machen.
Doch von der Atlas-Rakete wissen wir, dass
auch Stahl Probleme machen kann.
Diese war nämlich sehr schwer und brach so
zusammen.
Zumindest sieht die Aussenhaut so ziemlich
beeindruckend aus.
Eine Art soll die Hochglanz-Politur als eine
Art “Cool”-Faktor wirken und die entstehende
Hitze reflektieren.
Musk ist sich sicher, dass Stahl das bessere
Material für die Hülle ist.
Es sei leichter und das wegen seines Verhältnisses
zwischen Stabilität und Gewicht, der hohen
Temperaturbeständigkeit und des deswegen
geringeren Bedarfs an Hitzeschutz.
Und für den Hitzeschutz hat Musk einen besonderen
Plan.
Er schätzt, dass “Starship” mit 30.577
Kilometern pro Stunde durch die Mars- bzw
Erdatmosphäre eintreten könnte.
Dabei sei die Unterseite seines Raumschiffes
einer unfassbaren Temperatur von rund 1400
Grad Celsius ausgeliefert.
Und tatsächlich ist das heiß genug, um die
Stahl-Legierung zu zerstören.
Und so sieht Musk hier keineswegs tausende
Keramikfliesen, wie sie etwa von der NASA
eingesetzt werden.
Stattdessen setzt SpaceX darauf, Treibstoff
der Rakete durch winzige Löcher bluten bzw.
schwitzen zu lassen.
Dabei entsteht eine flüssige Schicht, die
zu einer Abkühlung führen würde.
Heißt also im Klartext: Der Raketenkörper
würde sich bei der Landung selbst abkühlen
- und zwar mit Flüssigbrennstoff.
Musk stellt sich eine Art Edelstahl-Hitzeschild
vor, das somit nicht nur für Abkühlung sorgt,
sondern zudem auch noch die Stahlkarosserie
stützt.
Ein Stück weit kann man diese Art von Kühlung
mit der Kühlung von Säugetier-Haut vergleichen:
der Schweiß wird aus den Poren ausgestoßen,
um eine zu hohe Körpertemperatur entgegenzuwirken.
Doch auch in der Raumfahrt ist dieses Konzept
nichts Neues.
Schon die NASA hat damit vor Jahrzehnten experimentiert.
Und hier hat sich des öfteren gezeigt, dass
es Probleme geben kann -. und zwar mit Löchern
im Hitzeschild, die blockiert und verstopft
sind sind.
Ein Ausweg könnte es beispielsweise sein,
Methan als Kühlmittel zu verwenden oder deutlich
mehr Poren anzubringen.
Und Methan wird ja auch der Treibstoff zusammen
mit flüssigem Sauerstoff sein, der damit
bereits an Bord ist.
Luftfahrtexpertinnen und -experten bezweifeln
allerdings, ob diese Ideen von Musk tatsächlich
umzusetzen sind.
Denn nicht nur der Ein- und Sinkflug, sondern
vor allem auch die Landung bedeuten eine riesige
Herausforderung - manchen Experten und Expertinnen
zufolge ist die Landung eines Raumschiffes
auf dem Mars etwa 100 Mal schwieriger als
die Mars-Landung eines auto-großen Roboters.
Und selbst da geht ja immer mal wieder etwas
schief.
So oder so kommt mit diesem Raumschiff die
Besiedlung von Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem
in greifbare Nähe.
Und damit auch komplett neue Perspektiven
der Erforschung.
Was könnten wir alles herausfinden, wenn
wir nicht nur unbemannt und mit Astronauten
lediglich Stippvisiten machen können.
Nuke Mars!
Will Elon Musk den Mars bombardieren?!
Anklicken, Anschauen und Astro Comics Abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran.